أنت بحاجة إلى حوالي سبع ساعات من النوم ،
أولئك الأشخاص الذين يقولون إنهم ينامون
على ما يرام وأربع أو خمس ساعات
لا يفعلون ذلك إذا كنت متعبًا تذهب إلى الفراش
وأنت لا تغفو ، ما
حدث لي  تنهض
من السرير وتفعل شيئًا آخر
قليلاً لا تريد أن تبدأ في
جعل سريرك مرتبطًا في
عقلك بمكان يمكنك الاستلقاء فيه مستيقظًا على
سريرك ليكون مكانًا
ستذهب إليه بالفعل  يفاجئ
الكثير من الناس بالنوم ، ولكن عندما لا تنام بشكل
كافٍ ، فإنك تبدأ في الواقع في تناول المزيد من الطعام ،
ولست متأكدًا تمامًا من سبب حدوث ذلك ، ولكن
يبدو أن هذه المنطقة من
الدماغ المعروفة باسم مركز الإشباع
والتي هي جزء من الدماغ يسمح لك
لن تشعر بالشبع تمامًا
عندما لا تحصل على قسط كافٍ من النوم إذا كان بإمكاني
القيام بشيء واحد فقط في شيء معين ،
إما إذا أعطوا ساعة أخرى من النوم أو قاموا
ببعض التمارين الرياضية ، فمن
المحتمل أن يفوزوا في الواقع بخمسة مرات
عندما تريد  نعسان ميت الساعة التاسعة
صباحا  ليلاً ثم عند الساعة 10 صباحًا ،
تستيقظ كثيرًا مرة أخرى وقد فاتتك نوعًا ما
نافذتك للذهاب للنوم ،
واستفد من هذه النوافذ أيضًا ، اكتشف أيضًا
ما نسميه جيدًا للنوم ، وعادة ما يكون النوم
أكثر برودة قليلاً في الغرفة يكون
أفضل في
مكان ما بين  تريد محاولة إيقاف تشغيل الأجهزة المحمولة بمقدار 68 درجة و 72 درجة مئوية
بقدر ما يمكنك قضاء
وقت طويل وإلقاء نظرة على ما تأكله إذا
كنت تتناول الكثير من الأطعمة المحتوية على الكافيين
أو الأطعمة المحفزة بأي شكل من الأشكال.
لتجنب أولئك القريبين من ذلك الوقت أيضًا